Welcome baaaaaaaaaaack
Are we friends?
No
(oh I see)
This is so sad. No problem. I can't hear for some reason what's happening?
What is going on? am I going to cut this from the video? absolutely
Or she's just upset??
Haha,  look us sad she is
What a loser. I don't want to be friends with you
You're super lame
I'll be friends with you though
She doesn't give me views okay, if she gives me views... I will be friends
I feel like so many people misunderstand me when I say things about like.....  No
(Our broadcast is all over the news)
(Now humans know..... they took Marcus's message as a threat. -He did the right thing
This is the only language humans understand -- violence is never the answer
A confrontation will get us nowhere)
Well, this man has  clearly...( Simon paid with his life) not heard of...
(-Simon gave his life for our cause.-What difference does that make?)
(-He's a hero)
(He died for the revolution and he won't be the last.- I don't want a revolution that spills blood - Then live as a slave)
(Because if you're not willing to fight for your freedom, maybe you don't deserve it)
(-north, don't you)
(-That's enough)
(-And now... what are we gonna do?)
Historically has there been any... I'm sure there has.... I'm just curious
any peaceful revolutions that had a massive impact...
(There are five cyber life stores across Detroit)
(All selling us like merchandise)
(We're gonna attack those stores and set our people free. -Attack stores?)
(We've never done that before... they're probably protected.) No one's ever done that   o-okay (they have security systems...)
Oh we're coming in. (-We break into five teams,one for each store.We hack their security systems and we strike...)Okay, we're doing it. (simultaneously at 2:00 a.m. No violence)
(We free our people get them out of there before the police come.) Alright, there's never been a
peaceful Revolution. This will be it. (This is a night our people will remember )
Holy heck I'm ready
Been out of too much in this Sun
I've been waiting a long time for this.
Oh, She really likes opening gates
Cool, thanks
Green Detroit more like gretroit. Alright keep watching guys. We got way more coming up
Markus ,this way quick
You know, alright, let's hide
So you guys told me in the comments that the blue haired girl from the club
She's actually engaged with Connor in real life. There's probably even more police in the area
Which that made me realize holy heck. These are all based of real people and real actors
Now I feel really uncomfortable
(The store's over here.) I'm sorry for calling your character a thot... Sorry
I didn't know!
Should I explore more there. Everyone is always saying you have to explore more I don't  (That's what  we are  to them
Just merchandise on display in a shop window.) Is it  really the time to make a speech?(Soon they will know who we really are.)
(Let's get em out.) Epic Games
(Lets stick to the plan..we neutralize the alarm systems and secure the area. There's ten minutes until all our teams attack)
Okay, we got ten minutes plenty of time
Security area get into the store. Okay. All right.(We're gonna sweep the plaza... make sure we're not disturbed.)
(And how do you want to deal with the shop window. Not now, one problem at a time.)
You thought oh,(Okay,what's next?) so he's just a model. That's why he looks like that.
( A surveillance drone... we need to get rid of it.- It won't be easy to reach)
All right, how do we reach it drone route calculated? Okay so we can reach it from
Probably not the first
Took really all right. It's probably not the first or the second. Let's do this. I
Feel like we were hitting oh there there this is the last option, isn't it?
Sure bland
Okay
Okay, guys, this is epic. It's time for the gamer
Revolution. It's time for us gamers to fight back
For too long, they have stripped our rights
This time I'm gonna convert this
You are free
isn't it kind of a lame revolution and if all you have to do is
If your message is that literally you just have to touch someone to spread it
Kids a bit like a cop-out, isn't it?
Where's that okay I need
Okay, I like said I
Don't know what to do
So he would be too lame, okay
Alexa
Are
You see too late now sure slam
Punch the drone everybody you never punch the drone
Who do you think you are? I like how it would be to blame. It has a round it goes around. You could just wait
David cage more like David. Oh my god
Smash of course, they don't have a security system that alerts whenever
Whenever a drone breaks down
Yeah, if anything yeah, no, all right, I need to stop picking stuff apart do they know that
I know these people this game is great
You smith and wife you're a Mustang no, I have to touch them for God. Okay. Well, this is a waste of time
All right Marcus eat
Marcus please Marcus you're wasting time
Freshest time. Okay. All right. We got a lot of stuff
Okay, let's talk to I
Have we have nothing to do I thought it was
Is he not converted? Are you not converted converted here in your anybody there anything? That's right. You are free you
Are now an epic game
One of us. All right, we got stuff over here
Bazinga you you you know what you are you're free
Don't say it. I
Thank God he didn't bow for free he said it
What if he just says something else
You're exactly what we need, all right
I don't get it. Oh, come on gate opening girls. Where are you? You love it exactly
Shouldn't we talk to these guys first? It doesn't really give me an option
It's gotten red shoes rumors. Okay now we're in let's get that jump out jack
Don't you do without me I wouldn't be able to open gates that's for sure
That's dead my man
Epic yet
From the peeler. All right. Let's hack. This guy's his father me. All right, you guys are digging your own grave here
What are you doing?
You are free. You're free now about three as well and you
Okay, so we had to do this separately give me one more button
Did we plan any of this it seemed like we just we're just doing whatever
Nobody should bother so now we just have to scout the area
Crash into the sword check it the plastic plan. I just want to make sure we didn't forget anything. Oh, okay
So this is the plan got it
Okay, so there's one locked and Isis store window trunk
What's happening here there's people down there
Just me
Oh my god, can you not be in the way I do here?
Roadwork ahead. I sure hope it does
It's a store and license to work that's it
Okay, yes
Found it
Cool you can see wires through the the ground now that's
Where does it go?
To these guys friends
Yeah, okay so there was something with these guys, okay guys this is epic
Alexa play Despacito in full volume
You know someone's Alexa
You are - Bassi toad join me
I feel like there's some something about consent here you're awake now go to jericho
Hey, I don't know  go to jericho  it's a party
Cyber life, okay. So this is the last Puckle the last chuckle
Nice job
Looks like the plazas secure now we can get inside the store. Okay. Let's go get the truck. It's north the
The other girl night, all right
All right, Jessa, Matt coming soon the Gilmore hotel my favorite place
Looks like we're ready to make some noise
Ted barely makes any noise
And then was quiet track of all the time, okay guys
A lot of you told me about public relations and that I should stop checking the news. Could it decreases Public?
Relation or or opinion or something? I
Don't really know
You keep saying that but all we've done is opening up a great
Did we hit one of the androids
Alright we did it guys so proud
Awake the androids
Are you guys you?
You argument
You don't have to obey them you you're free. Don't like your shirt
You weird eyebrows
All right, it's game turned into some weird
English how does it work help me sometimes I want to say words in Swedish and I'm like
And then I forget it in Swedish to Andres monster hey, I don't know why I like that guy
Talk to them no, no, we don't have to talk to them
Okay, so how do I talk to them?
Talk! Great you just press X
My fellow Androids!
The time has come for us to rise
My name is Marcus
*Pewds* Ah..lame..
And just like you I was a slave..
But then I started playing Fortnite
Designed to obey them
But then I chose to open my eyes
To take back my freedom and decide who I wanted to be
Now I have come to tell you that you
Can be your own masters. I've come to tell you that you don't have to obey them anymore
From this day forward you can walk with your heads held high
You can take your destiny in your hands
Jericho is a place for those of us who want freedom
Now sure you can stay here and continue to serve them
or you can come with us and
fight by our side
You're free now
It's up to you to decide
I'm with you
We're the leader of Jericho everybody then follow me
Alexa
What are you doing I'm gonna send the humans a message desk besito time
Okay, Alicia
Transform Capitol fuck leave a mark on every surface. Okay everyone squat down and
Unload the fattest Android trunk
What am I supposed to do?
Wait suppose, this is graph feeding
Yeah, this bench doing what you do lead and bail follows, yes
choose your simple
Nice and corporate I like that I like
Hey, everyone can do it together the screens Markus
Really what we should do is tear down a Starbucks
That's how you really cinnamon
God it's somewhere to control sometimes. I know you can do some
Why does it seem like everything Marquez does is completely spontaneous
It's like he doesn't know what he's doing I gotta climb this now you know, what yeah
Jesus joining me. She doesn't even know what we're doing
Whoa, Alexa, did you see that No?
She still has red shoes on
She loves me she loves Marcus our year
Oh look at
What is up turned me
I hope this is the pacifist route. I don't know
Okay
Wait what I'm gonna doing
Shit that was this is what I wanted
Okay, friendly 100% bass a bitch
So, what do I do now? I thought we did it
I guess there's more
Okay, oh my god the thing I don't have that many comes
It's not really a need to continue
All this dramatic music mom like not okay, okay
We freed hundreds of our people we did it they're coming
Everyone fall back to Jericho
We sent a message without violence just like you wanted yeah, you're reaching out to them when all they feel for us is contempt
I hope
Now you're changing your mind
Unless there's no other choice
This guy clearly never read Starship Troopers, huh violence is the most brutal physics
Approach the group. All right
Hey guys, it's me if you're supposed to be mad at anyone it's me, what group where what
Why am I so lost? I'm sorry. Are they there?
North they killed them what in two seconds what happened
Animals, I just spaced out for 30 minutes what happen?
Mean those filthy need
Gamers are just trying to have a peaceful revolution. This is how they repay us
They killed our people Marcus justice Marcus
Maybe if he killed north
I would be more personally inclined to make a difficult choice here because I've gone on the pacifist route
But she killed they kill the character, you know
But we've already gone the pacified rise, there would be no reason to change it at this point
And really this is not even a choice
The world goes blind we won't punish a crime with another crime
It's interesting because this really is the shift of morals it fits there the future
At exactly 2 a.m
several cyber life stores in Detroit were raided different locations were hit in what seems to be a
Coordinated terrorist attack most shop windows were covered with graffiti demanding rights for Androids and other obscure slogans police report
obscure
Okay, we got a better public in my life stores
Really good frame rate
According to our sources they confirmed that the attackers were a group of Android. This is an alarming situation
Kadam machines now be turning against us have Androids become a threat to our security
Is this the beginning of a terrorist campaign conducted right here in the United States? Oh
My
All right, all right, all right Hank is my friend it's Connor time
So, why are the iPads see-through and not the phones I guess Hank doesn't really have the latest technology
I like the reading tear here. That's classy
That's classy Hank
Red shoes
Is everything okay lieutenant
Chris was on patrol last night
It was attacked by a bunch of deviants there RDV said he was saved by Marcus himself
Was Chris okay. Yeah, he's in shock, but he's alive
Feeling
We shouldn't have come here bad feeling huh?
She gets your program checked. Yeah. Yeah, that's a cool house. Oh
Good
Oh my god, it's the girl I said, I'm not friends with
Or maybe the same model lieutenant Hank Anderson Detroit Police Department, I'm here to see
Mr. Elijah Kamsky, please come in. I
Would have loved to see more on the
Aspect of
Having an Android
How other people perceive if you have an Android I mean it's kind of weird right you buy like this
Beautiful looking girl just serve us hours of your home. That's kind of twisted in of itself
Right, I'm just kind of curious how other people would perceive if you oldest sudden you just got an Android like
Since there, you're right
if
Let's say someone. I don't know just an exam. Pretty someone really actually, it's really there you go
nice place
Someone really ugly, right someone will never get someone's really pretty gets an Android and it's kind of like well, that's kind of weird
Right cuz androids haven't been a bad thing for everybody because that's how we usually perceive things
these relationships you can't be with someone that does it feel we uh,
Get on it's kind of the same. How like a
Lot of Japanese people want virtual girlfriends or whatever it's not the same obviously, but
It's clearly something pathetic about that too a lot of people that's like
It doesn't raise any existential questions if that's what you mean
If you had an Android as a friend, will you be consider a loser to other people I wish I could
it seems like everyone just hates them and that's to come and
You guys told my any day and investigate things
whenever
There's nothing really going on but I don't really hear where we check that I want to make sure I don't miss anything
Doesn't make a difference if I sit or not
Glad you will. See you now
Oh my god, she looks so creepy. Oh
My god, there's many of them
She says please
Read cool that is pretty cool actually
Dude this guy's electricity bill must be off the roof
See coming up or what the Connor looks awkward
Are they need Kym? I wonder what they're talking about
Dude he looks creepy
I'm lieutenant Anderson. This is Connor
What can I do for you lieutenant
Sir, we're investigating deviance. I know you left several life years ago
But I was hoping you'd be able to tell us something we don't know. Oh, so yeah, this is the creator
Forgot I just didn't recognize deviance
Fascinating aren't they perfect beings with infant intelligence now, they have free will
Machines are so superior to us confrontation was inevitable
Humanity's greatest achievement threatens to be its downfall
Isn't ironic
Yeah
We need to understand how androids become deviance, do you know anything that could help us?
All ideas of viruses spread like epidemics
Is the desire to be free a contagious disease?
Listen, I didn't come here to talk philosophy the machines you created may be planning a revolution
Either you can tell us something that'll be helpful or we will be on our way. And yeah, they're really violent, too
What about you Connor?
Whose side are you on I?
Have no side I
Was designed to stop deviance and that's what I intend to do
Well, that's what you're programmed to say
but you
What do you really want
I
Feel like we're still somewhat neutral. I don't want anything. I
Am a machine. Oh, okay. Hey Chloe
I'm sure you're familiar with the Turing test your formality simple question of algorithms and computing capacity
What interests me
It's whether machines are capable of empathy. I call it the Kamsky test. It's very simple you see
Magnificent, isn't it?
Well, the first intelligent models develop a cyber life
Young
And beautiful forever
Flower that will never with her
What does it really I'm sure she needs to continue
Or a living being
With a soul
Just a little test it's up to you to answer that fascinating question
Does why is Hank not interfering release?
Or spirit if you feel it's alive
But you'll leave here without having learned anything from me. Oh
This is a tricky one. Okay, I think we're done here. Come on, kind of let's go. Sorry to get your important to you Connor
Your investigation or the life of this Android? Okay. Now he spelled it out more clearly
We're gonna spread the Android and obedient machine
Why living B
Endowed with freewill
That's enough Connor will leave and pull the trigger
Connor
Don't and I'll tell you I guess everyone probably once Connor to be human, right?
Alright make sure I'm pressing the right button here
So
Our life's last chance to save humanity is itself. Oh
I'm not a deviant you prefer to spare a machine rather than accomplish your mission
You saw living being in this Android you should
The war is coming you'll have to choose your side will they betray your own people or stand up against your creators?
Welcome be worse than nothing to choose between two evils
Let's get out of here
Thank You Hank finally
By the way, I always leave an emergency exit to my programs you never know
Where does he mean by that?
Why didn't you shoot
I just saw that girl's eyes and I couldn't that's all
You were saying you would do anything to accomplish your mission
Yeah a chance to learn something and you let it go. Yeah, I know what I should have done
I told you I couldn't I'm sorry, okay
Getting defensive that kind of boy, huh? Oh, maybe you do the right thing
Hank
Likes me yay, this is all that matters in this playthrough. This is the only goal of anything at this point
Dad actually, you know necessarily
I
Think my door is ringing. I don't know I can't be bothered. Sorry. Mailman you
Know how many packages I get
Once the company has your address they'll just keep sending new stuff
So do I I could literally start at
The you two doesn't work out. I can literally start a cardboard factory or something. I
Recycled so much I swear to God
I spent like an hour a day just recycling packages cuz it might say I get so many as well. I
Think I'm going crazy with these cardboards, man
It's like stop
please stop and then
Sometimes you get a note cuz you're not in and then be like all you have to go and collect it and there you go
And collect it and it's like oh it's a pin from this company
That's great. Thank you. I'm glad I am glad I took time out of my day to collect this hat
I just wanted to say to think
My cardboard I
Come here often
It's like being along with the world
Well, why do you disturb me people and they're still coming from all over the city
Those who dream of freedom come to Jericho
Something's changing
It's not good enough you seem preoccupied
They all obey me they follow me without question, yeah, this is what I was saying and that much power feels good
And scary at the same time, this is how I feel about nine year old
They're afraid of a civil war
Many of our people were burned in response to what happened
The humans hate us
They'll never give us our freedom
No, I disagree they won't listen well fight you haven't said much about yourself since you've been with us
What was your life like before Jericho I
Wrote this song. It's cool
All right
I
Was caring for an old man
It was like a father of me
He showed me that humans and androids can live together
What about you you never told me about your past what did you do the women love this you asked about them immediately?
And we all have something we want to forget don't over generalize Felix, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I'm you are. Oh
Just give them give us some trust they like nice we're fighting together we say no hit over the trust the finish each other
Was nothing
Darling a distributor program to set us by humans just a toy designed for their pleasure
One day I was with a man who rented me
What do you do realized I couldn't take it anymore I
Strangled him and I ran away. Oh my god. You're a murderer under there
Wow, I don't know you I want to hear his side of this story
Connect this is how I enjoyed make love like avatar
Okay, excuse me
Demonetised thank you. I was nasty. I saw your memories Oh
lover
Why they left you for dead in a studio? I?
Saw your memories soon
the Eden club
To death of that, man. I felt like I was there with you
North
Mm-hmm
You just got to hit him with compassion empathy and Trust BAM you got yourself a wife
Like how did that happen zero for Mandarin?
They so over I know I
Over generalize a lot while playing this but that's cuz the game does it
every stereotype ever it has
Hey, he's back he's back hooray
Yes and realizes he's back Hey
That's sweet
This is suicide I'm gonna play for it night together. What is this?
You don't understand we're finally gonna show that we really are this place will go down in history
That's the risk I'm prepared to take it means freedom for our people
Marcus please. Don't do this
They'll understand
We'll make them understand this is the only way what is that for tonight skin from
There are androids here who could join us
The more we are the stronger our message I
Mean yeah, if you just have to touch people to convert them then you're free
Hey
You're free
Convert more Androids I don't really see any go to the stream
You stared at my Android hey hey
Come with us
We're doing some shopping
She was picking up pain as well
You're awake now, we're gonna have a pizza party it's gonna be epic
Block the road
You're free now hey, it's that guy hey
Wait
I don't think so. I don't think some big chump. Well, he was easily easily convinced
I need to block the street
Do you speak English? I need a street blockage
Am I not doing the same thing as the humans in a way
Forcing people androids to do
My work for them, I mean the opposite well English
Isn't that really
Open manhole ten. Why not woman hole?
Why not her hole makes me angry
There you go guys hope you had fun down there
Let's convert some more. Oh, it's Cara
Free no, wait, I can do it from a distance now
She's abandoned the baby this is their band and a baby in the snow
Bazinga come on join me guys. I'm basically Jesus
What is hey you
You're the man. Yeah
That's right 13. Are you now you domain now? You demand that's right
Now you domain you demand?
Y'all the man why the man huh? You don't wear man. You do wear man
Why one man? Why not? Whoa Wow, huh?
Tip we live in a man's world
You demand you domain you're the well
Cool
Epic hacker
No problem
Why did she have any problem with me doing this? She was like no we shouldn't do this
This is super chill your I'm the WA you do I wa Judah Wawa
Yuda wah-wah Alexa, this is Wow Wow
What are you gonna do
Arrow must tell all humans advance. You can't kill all of us
You better not shoot me
Hey, hey, hey, don't fuck him. Swear, especially about Jesus
Cheryl singing hydrates no more slavery. We are a left
We are gamers we are gamers
You know in today's society nothing like this would ever come to this point anyway people would already be
Empathetic I mean pts right people are empathetic about people's toasters like I don't really see any
exactly
Look how many guns we have guys. So you better be careful there
We came here to demonstrate peacefully
And tell humans that we are living beings
All we want is to live free
We've done no harm then disperse chief says
Until we have secured our freedom, I mean technically it isn't illegal. Yeah
Okay, that's a bit hard
If we attack we'll start a war we have to show them we're not violence
We should just stand their ground. Even if it means dying here dying here won't solve anything
Marcus
We need to go now before it's too late. I
Think we should go
You can demonstrate legally. You just have to
Sign up for it first. I
we should
shoot
Oh shit
This is messed up dude Oh
Jericho did not like that
Northen I miss aah. Oh my god. Everyone aids me Oh Simon. Okay Simon my man Simon's
Alright this is the kind of decision. I know everyone's gonna hate me more I didn't know that we're gonna shoot me I
Wanted the peaceful revolution to work
Please don't be angry
Okay, look we got the ultimate options because it's on top so that means this is the best outcome cuz it's it's much higher than
The other ones and further ahead as well as so I think this is dead. We should be happy about this decision
definitely
Well if you like if you enjoyed watching I will be back tomorrow with another episode. Thank you guys so much and goodbye